[Musique]
nicolas sarkozy
je ne voulais pas je ne voulais
absolument pas cette réaction bien au
contraire vous devriez l'applaudir parce
que c'est lui qui a fait le grenelle de
l'environnement
avec alain juppé avec jean louis borloo
avec nathalie kosciusko morizet avec
chantal jouanno ce sont des grands noms
de l'écologie c'est eux qui ont fait
leur avance et l'écologie comme jamais
au cours des dernières années toutes ces
personnes sont de votre famille
politique donc encore une fois chers
élus si vous avez des chaufferies bois
si vous avez des méthaniseurs si vous
avez des réseaux de chaleur si vous avez
la géothermie et des déchetteries c'est
au grenelle de l'environnement que vous
le devez 7 à votre famille politique que
vous le devez